- Hey guys, this novel
coronavirus pandemic
has truly affected all
of us across the globe,
but one of the hardest hit communities
has been healthcare frontline workers.
This means doctors, nurses,
CMAs, respiratory therapists,
technicians, custodial
staff, and so many more.
Today I'd like to take a
focus and celebrate doctors,
in memory of those who've
laid down their lives
in the battle against COVID-19.
I sat down, and I interviewed
over 100 physicians
to get their take, their experiences,
and learn their perspectives
about the coronavirus.
Know that all the revenue
generated from this video,
AdSense, donations, and even
merch sales, link down below,
are all going to the CDC Foundation
to help continue this
battle against COVID-19.
The first question I asked these doctors,
what do you think is not
getting enough attention?
- I wish there was more credit
and awareness being given
to other members of the healthcare teams,
aside from just the
doctors and the nurses.
- Techs, transporters,
housekeeping, kitchen staff,
valets, operators.
- X-ray, laboratory, radiology
techs, EMT, janitorial staff.
- Cafeteria workers, the
respiratory therapists, the nurses,
and everyone else here on the frontline is
towards our abilities to do our jobs.
- The number of doctors and
healthcare professionals
out there who have gotten seriously ill,
even lost their lives
fighting this disease.
- Some healthcare workers have
been disciplined for speaking
up about the lack of personal
protective equipment.
- Testing is an area we need
a huge amount of focus on
and attention on in the UK.
- We need antibody tests.
We need to know who has immunity.
- In many communities, the small number
of cases being reported
is simply a reflection
of lack of testing.
- How coronavirus is and will
affect certain communities,
our homeless community,
our community of people
with special needs.
- The domestic abuse and domestic
violence that is happening
during a pandemic with
victims being in the same home
as perpetrators for longer periods of time
in this quarantine.
- We've limited and cut the number
of visits a woman can
have before she delivers.
- Visitors, family, really
no one is allowed to be
at the bedside when you're
infected with COVID.
- If you look closely, you will see that
there are young people,
who are otherwise well,
who can get seriously ill.
- We can't really see the emotional toll
that the outbreak has on us.
- The effect that this is all having
on our mental health and well-being.
- Mental health problems don't stop
just because we are having an
infectious-disease pandemic.
- I've had patients who haven't been able
to get cancer surgery, who've
had significant heart problems
and not been able to get them worked up.
- If people who now feel sick from cancer
are now discouraged
from going to hospitals
because all the attention
now is on COVID-19,
then we're gonna miss
some of those patients.
- Right now we're postponing
all the non-urgent cases,
and when things are lifted,
we're gonna see everyone
come back all at once.
- How is one supposed to
date in this point in time?
Are we just supposed to get to know people
by Zoom and FaceTime?
- Yeah, virtual dating is a thing now.
For my next question, I
asked, what does it mean
for you to be a doctor now?
- It means a 30-minute
decontamination routine before I get
to hug my kids every time I
come home from the hospital.
- Practicing medicine
during this pandemic means
what it always means,
protecting the vulnerable.
- This is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to boldly fulfill my oath
and desire to save lives.
- The COVID-19 pandemic has me in a place
where I have never felt more
connected to my profession.
- I have an opportunity to step
up and really honor my oath.
- I really feel like it's a
privilege for me to be able
to practice medicine during the pandemic.
It allows me to serve my community
when my community needs me most.
- I'm old enough to have
lived through the early years
of the AIDS epidemic, and
it had a similar feeling.
You knew you were in the middle
of something incredibly important.
- My mother gave me a magnet
a long time ago that said,
"Not all heroes wear capes.
"Some of them wear stethoscopes."
- I'm not running away from it.
I'm running toward it.
- We're ready, we signed up
for this, we took an oath.
- It's a privilege to be
a part of the solution.
- It's an honor to care for
patients and their families and
to help navigate them through
these very challenging times.
- Medicine is a calling and a vocation.
I've never viewed it as a job.
- This isn't a job.
This is a calling.
- I couldn't agree more.
Next I asked, how have you
been personally affected
by the coronavirus?
- When we put a breathing
tube in for a patient,
which we have to do for
almost every surgery,
we're really exposed to everything that's
in that patient's mouth
or throat or airway.
It's like looking down
the barrel of a gun.
- I'll be moving out of our house soon
and into some place that's
closer to the hospital
and where I won't risk
infecting my own family.
- Should I move out, should
I isolate within the home?
- I haven't seen my mom or
my dad or any family members
in the last few weeks.
- I have some sick family members.
I don't know when I'll see them next.
- I wasn't able to kiss my wife
on our anniversary this year
because of coronavirus.
- My beautiful wife and I
are about to bring new life
into this world, and with
that comes fear, worry,
and anxiety.
- Both of my daughters work with me here
at the Cleveland clinic.
I'm worried for the family,
but we're gonna do this.
- My entire family lives and practices
a self-care survival
simile, and when I read
in the news that 2,027
physicians, as of yesterday,
have contracted the virus
and many have died from it,
it gave me chills.
- I recently got sick with a lot
of the features of COVID-19.
Without testing, I've
got no way of knowing
if I had it for sure.
I don't know if I'll be infected again.
I don't know if I'm going
to infect my patients.
- I did get corona.
I was actually sick for
two weeks, had pneumonia,
and it was probably the
worst health experience
that I have ever been through.
- I developed a fever and a
lot of the COVID symptoms.
When I ended up in the emergency room,
all I could think about
was when I recover,
will this make me immune so
I can get back out there?
- For the first time ever, lately,
I've been having the sense of uneasiness
as I drive into work.
- I've personally seen a lot
of death that I don't know
if residency could ever prepare you for.
- Because our pain clinics
closed down last week,
and before I'll be transitioning
to telemedicine soon,
there's still a gap where
I will be unemployed
as a pain management fellow,
and that leaves me financially unstable.
- So I'm still paying rent,
overhead, staff, supplies,
all of the above with basically no income.
- I'm a physician on O'ahu,
and it's challenging caring
for my neighbor island patients
on Maui and the Big island.
- Hydroxychloroquine has
been getting a lot of press
during this pandemic, and the availability
of this medication has been
a big concern for myself
and for my patients.
- I've been forced to
delay important heartbeat
and heart rhythm procedures
for several of my patients.
- I lost childcare, so
my toddler keeps barging
into all of my appointments,
and that's probably a HIPAA violation.
- Hey, I can relate.
Bear walks into some of
my patient visits too.
Next I asked, how can we help from home?
- Believe it or not,
not everyone is taking
social distancing seriously.
- The virus doesn't spread on its own.
People spread the virus,
so you are on the frontline
in this pandemic.
- Even small indulgences,
like going to a park
around other people, can
have huge consequences
that you don't even feel in the moment.
- Treat every outside contact
as something potentially
infected, no matter how healthy
or safe someone or something looks.
- This thing does not
care what you look like,
how much money you have,
or how wealthy you are,
so you have to stay home.
- No cheating.
I know it gets really
boring at home sometimes,
and all you want to do is
just be with your friend just
for a minute, but please,
for our sake, stay home.
- Stay home.
That's how you fight the virus.
- Get comfortable, and stay there.
Netflix and chill.
YouTube and thrill.
- Please, please, please stay home.
Help us help you.
- Help me help you.
- Stay hydrated, get some
sleep, eat healthy, don't smoke,
and please do some exercise
while you're at home.
- Here's my prescription for you.
Stay home.
- We are not stuck at home.
We are safe at home.
- Safe at home, not stuck at home.
And please treat everyone with kindness.
- Everyone knows someone
who is putting their life
at risk by working during
these difficult times.
Just send them a thank you.
- Continue sending positive
vibes and continue reaching out
to those who are in their support system.
We need their help.
- And just be kind to each other.
Everyone's having a hard time.
- Physical distancing is crucial,
but it should not cause social isolation.
- Call or FaceTime your
friends, your family,
your significant others.
- The virus mainly infects
through mucus membranes
of the eyes, nose and mouth,
so even if we wear gloves
and we wear masks, if we touch our face,
we can still get infected.
- Washing your hands, and
no I'm not just talking like
oh, wash, wash, wash, and you're done.
I'm talking a full 20 seconds.
- Wash your hands.
- Wash your hands multiple
times throughout the day.
- Really diligent hand washing.
- Wash your hands.
- And as I say to my five year
old, don't pick your nose.
- Be wary of the browsers and the pickers
at the grocery store.
You know I'm talking about,
those people that are picking
up avocados and putting them right back.
- By being very careful
of your internet hygiene
because spreading false
information can be deadly.
- Everyone has a role
to play in making sure
that we spread correct information.
- Stop spreading
misinformation on social media.
I think this is very important.
- Just following credible media outlets.
Don't give in to the hysteria.
- The top thing on my mind, is remembering
to stay flexible and
lean into uncertainty.
- Have those difficult
end-of-life discussions.
You will feel at peace knowing
your loved one's wishes,
whether the time comes
tomorrow or a decade from now.
- Ask neighbors to put
up a red piece of paper
in their window if they
need assistance immediately.
A yellow piece means I need
help, but not urgently.
And green means things are okay.
- And please know that when the scientists
are saying these things,
we're not saying them
because we're out to get you.
We're saying them because
we care about you.
- That's right.
We're on team you.
All right, my final question,
what gives you hope?
- It gives me goosebumps when I think
about what you see around you.
- The doctors, nurses, social workers,
respiratory therapists,
environmental services.
- Each and every one of
us is doing what we can.
- It's the fact that I
have a great ICU team.
I have the best ICU nurses in the world.
- The unity, the compassion, and empathy.
- Humanity exists, and
we're all in this together.
- I live in New York City,
and every night at 7:00,
the entire city breaks
out in cheer and applause
for all the healthcare workers.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- I'm hearing from families who are having
more family meals, more family meetings,
they're playing board games,
they're communicating,
they're talking.
- People are coming together,
and they are helping
out their neighbors.
- Letters like this in my
mailbox from my neighbor,
spreading love across this country.
- Every patient that I called,
the first thing they
asked is how was I doing.
- The outpouring of love and support
from communities all around the world,
showing their support for
healthcare workers, like me,
on the frontline.
- All of our frontline
workers, in hundreds of roles,
inside the hospital and outside of it,
working their tails off every single day.
- My trainees all stepping up to volunteer
to help in the ICU.
- Healthcare professionals
everywhere are stepping up
instead of backing down.
- The emergency department
staff, now more than ever.
- We've put aside all turf wars
and inter-departmental bickering.
- The fact that the world
has set aside its differences
to work on novel treatments, vaccines,
and drugs for this virus.
- The people donating and making supplies.
- Like when we see businesses
that stop their work
and start producing equipment
for healthcare providers.
- Even famous fashion
designers, like Chanel
and Christian Siriano are
making masks and gowns.
- The numbers are getting better.
Prevention does work.
- Seeing people on their
balconies applauding those
on the frontline gives me hope.
And seeing science
working, creating vaccines,
creating treatments is what gives me hope.
- I'm fighting for the hope
that one day, very soon,
we overcome this, that we
get back to normal life
and don't take the small
things for granted again.
- And you know what gives me hope?
The fact that I was able to get over 100
of my physician colleagues
to make this video for you.
I usually sign off my videos by saying
stay happy and healthy.
But for this one, let's
do something different.
Stay alert, not anxious.
- [Everyone] Alert, not anxious.
Alert, not anxious.